the EEG a Chinese woman attempts to eat
pizza with a pair of chopsticks while a
male voiceover gives her directions this
clip posted on Dolce & Gabbana's social
media cans and sparked fury in China
with accusations of racism and cultural
ignorance if they continue to adopt as
vicious attitude then of course we can't
accept it and we need to boycott the
brand but if they apologize and truly
recognize their mistakes it would be
understandable we think Dolce &
Gabbana's art was biased and showed
misunderstanding towards China we feel
very uncomfortable when we see it to
make matters worse the brand's
co-founder Stefano Gabbana known for
being outspoken later appeared to insult
Chinese people in a private chat on
Instagram the designer later claimed his
account had been hacked
in a statement Dolce & Gabbana described
the events as unfortunate but the damage
was done
calls for a boycott ensued the Chinese
government even weighed in calling out
the fashion house for lacking respect
all in all a PR disaster China is a huge
market for Dolce & Gabbana a recent
study shows that consumers their account
for a third of global spending on luxury
goods the brand had been hoping to make
a major splash with its Shanghai Fashion
Show instead it's managed to become the
talk of the town for all the wrong
reasons
on the backlash in China is strong and
the fallout is growing and to take us
through this a little bit more we have
DW social media editor Carl announcement
here Carl
a Titan luxury meets one of the world's
largest consumer markets here how much
trouble is Dolce Gabanna in yeah they're
in trouble you can put it that way
they're in trouble
Dolce Gabanna this these ads are not
being received well in China we can
start by just showing you some of the
fallout on Chinese social media where
many are calling out the company and you
can see that even includes the company's
own brand ambassador in China his name
is Carrie Wang here he has publicly
actually
Mining from that post with a scathing
letter that he just posted to Weibo
that's China's version Twitter and
Estelle Chen she's a Chinese French
model speaking out here as well
you say she says that the company you
don't love China you love money
China is rich but also rich in values
and culture and the Chinese won't spend
a penny on a brand that does not respect
that there's been plenty of backlash
from Chinese citizens as well who saw
these ads and that can be summed up
pretty well in a really well done parody
video of those ads here's a little bit
of it take a look Chinese spouts up
welcome to the dolce & gabbana in
Spanish Oh II do it's fork and knife
episode 1 today we see there on the
right the parody video a kind of the
opposite right a Western man struggling
to eat Chinese food with a knife and
fork you know how do I do this of course
the joke is it's ridiculous that Chinese
people would you know how to eat pizza
right as for those original ads they've
been taken down now in China but they
are still available right now I just
checked before the show they're on Dolce
Gabbana's Instagram account there's
still Apple so their own spokespeople
are coming out consumers are coming out
here the parody videos right there
pretty funny what is Dolce Gabanna
itself have to say they're still running
the ads you said they don't very
receptive no the company did release an
official statement on some of its social
media channels you could kind of call it
a semi apology here's a bit from that
letter it says in part what happened
today was very unfortunate not only for
us but also for the people who worked
day and night to bring this event
referring to that cancelled Fashion Show
to life from the bottom of our hearts
we'd like to express our gratitude to
our friends and our guests I mean what's
missing from this statement right the
words I'm sorry
yeah you don't find it there now the
company is in more trouble yet again
apparently screenshots have surfaced
that allegedly show a conversation with
Stefano Gabbana in which he makes more
insulting comments about China
he says that's not him that as account
was hacked but clearly the the anger is
far from over in China I just be clear
this is an executive from Dolce Gabanna
or an official from the company so what
does this potentially mean for the
company again one of the world's largest
consumer markets here you probably don't
want to anger it yeah I mean this could
have a pretty big impact on their bottom
line I mean the company's products as
you mentioned
been pulled from online retailers
they're also being pulled off shelves
real shelves and in stores in China as
well and it's a big market for these
kind of luxury brands right Chinese
consumers spent more than 100 billion
dollars last year on luxury items that's
nearly one third of the global market so
they really can't afford this kind of
bad publicity so a lot at stake there
Karan Osmond DW social editor social
media editor thank you very much